What's that Lama and um,
and the Disney Crisco.
I'm thinking about in person hand crew for some reason.
Yeah.
A viral New York Times article featured 36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We wanted to see what would happen if we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
Hey,
my heart,
why is my heart going like this?
Calm down.
My name is Jonathan Gaurano.
I'm nervous because,
okay.
What happens if I walk and like spill the tea or worse like I burp or like I
fall down.
Well hello.
Hi,
my name is Hannah.
This is my first time on a blind date.
I've only dated three people in my entire life.
So this is something I'm curious to experience.
Oh,
nice.
Double.
Hello.
Thank you so much.
Oh,
nice tattoo on your foot.
I am baffled as well.
Thank you.
I said it on your arm there.
Oh thank you.
Do they represent anything?
This is um,
evergreen trees.
Okay.
I'm from Washington.
Oh Nice.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Like my roots and in a sense.
Okay.
Alright.
And this one or is this like a spring break situation and you're like,
Hashtag Yolo.
Yeah,
I know.
It says I love you.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
so what's your name?
Oh,
my name is Jonathan.
And what is your name then?
I'm Hannah.
Nice to meet you.
Yes.
Right.
You're a pal.
And from there you go,
Jonathan.
Yes.
Okay.
What'd you like to be famous and in what way?
Ah,
not really.
Okay.
A more influential maybe like let's say for example,
I write a book.
Okay.
And then someone reads it.
It's like,
oh,
this guy is so cool.
And then you're walking down the street and so,
and that person who read the book goes,
Oh my God,
you're not present.
Has a great mind Jonathan.
And I'm like,
yes I am.
Jonathan.
Pleased to meet you.
I think that way also where like motivate someone to do something.
Yeah.
So that not that type of fame.
What about you?
I think that I wouldn't want to be famous necessarily.
I think I'd want to be influential.
What would it be like?
What does that mean mission that you have,
do you think?
I think too though of our identity,
I think there's a lot of voices in the world is telling us what we should be.
Okay.
Whereas I think that if you are someone who is confidently and beautiful
yourself and authentic and real and raw and vulnerable of people,
I think it really opens doors,
which is I think what we're doing right now.
No one that's really like opening doors.
No,
we're doing this is just,
Oh,
I have three sisters and they would probably like relate to you.
Yeah.
I love your rings again.
Thank you.
It's like a,
what's that Lama and um,
in the Disney Crisco,
I'm thinking about it in person.
Crew for some reason.
Yes.
It's probably just monitoring.
That's what I need.
Oh my God.
And that's exactly what I need right now.
Yeah.
Oh,
thank God.
What is the greatest accomplishment of your life?
I was 17 years old.
This is the,
I think the 17 years old.
I'm driving and I was talking to my brother like,
ah,
I got rejected from four colleges.
I just have one left.
We go to the house.
And right now this woman is that we're living with has like DSL,
like Internet.
I'm trying to get into UC Berkeley and we pressed the button and it's the DSL,
like just,
just,
just dish,
dish.
And slowly but surely I see the words congratulations.
And my brother and I,
we scream or crying.
I'm jumping on the bed.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I get out the door,
I get on my knees and look in the rain.
I'm like,
yes,
thank you so much.
And I think at that moment,
my life just drastically changed for the better.
So I think that's my biggest accomplishment that I like and in my head so far.
What about,
what about yours?
I did,
um,
my senior year of high school got to compete nationally in a competition for
musical theater.
Right.
And I think that through that experience in New York,
that grueling,
um,
bootcamp of Broadway,
so to speak,
I got to really see how dedicated and passionate people are about what,
what storytelling has topic.
Um,
so you're a story teller.
That's awesome.
I love it.
I love tea.
I love that acting like enters you into different areas,
different cultures,
different,
right.
And the 1920s,
all of a sudden you're an alien.
And most importantly I think it gives,
it gives a voice to the marginalized,
I think.
Nice.
Thank you.
Okay.
Sorry.
Good.
Yeah.
So that's why I love what I do and that's,
I think my biggest accomplishment was trusting that I was meant to do this.
I like that.
That's good.
No,
no idea yet.
People don't care about under resource communities or marginalized community do
sometimes and just push yourself and you can do it through our,
yeah.
How do you feel about your relationship with
your mother?
I think my mom is probably one of the strongest women I know.
I'm just,
because I think she embodies,
um,
grace and forgiveness.
My parents' relationship was a little bit rocky for a while and growing up,
divorced,
um,
kind of,
but then came back together.
So just like this beautiful story of like overcoming challenges and
reconciliation and healing.
So just the fact that she came back and um,
wow bestowed grace and mercy upon my father was like really beautiful to me to
watch what a brave and she's wonderful.
Yeah.
Azure relationship with your mom.
Okay.
So I have six younger siblings.
Wow.
You have a big family.
Oh yes.
I love them.
They're my rock.
I mean this is where the tattoo is.
Okay.
I was gonna ask you to describe that.
It's a,
all my siblings,
all six of them,
and then one of them,
you know,
it was queer and so I decided to make the color of a color of love,
which is cool.
Um,
single mom of the seven unlike,
uh,
my father,
she did not leave us,
which is really great.
Like she stuck with us and then she decided to go back to school,
Breanna Sander,
her pharmacy degree or license.
And even though she's 60 years old,
she knows she's grinding away being pharmacist.
But I look at her and I think,
wow,
I respect you so much.
You've,
you've,
you've sacrificed so much of your life for us and for that,
I will always love her for that.
When did you last cry in front of another person?
Was it by herself?
If someone's like with me and we're having a very deep conversation and they
start to cry,
right.
I'll either ha only they're not crying and like want to be the strong person for
them or I'll completely just like cry with them.
Like it's like the silent tears where it's just like you're staring at them and
it's just like a waterfall,
you know?
Wow.
I bet.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm a crier I guess.
Yeah.
And you know,
typical you're sitting in the car and you're play like moonlight by Ariana
Grande Day and it's pleasant,
clean.
Yeah.
And as it's going,
you're just thinking about,
you know,
memories of your life and then you were just driving alone is like,
it's like a little bit dark and a one lane road and of course you begin to like
cry.
But I think the biggest crying situation I guess,
uh,
like last year I got into like a major car accident and my car did like a 360
degree thing and I landed on its tires thankfully.
And so then I just went into the shower,
I turned on the shower and there's blood was like flow hanging all over.
I just broke down for a second.
I think that's the last time was a major crime.
Everything else is just intermittent driving in a car.
Ariana Grande.
Thanks for sharing that though.
That was really cool of you to share.
Thank you so much.
The final task is without speaking,
stare into each other's eyes for four minutes.
That's what we're going to do.
Yeah,
so the eyes are like I for sure,
I think,
or like a window into the soul,
so it's like very vulnerable.
So you ready for this?
Oh my God.
It's actually an acting technique we use in class.
Zen for a second.
Okay.
I think it's,
yeah.
All right.
Great.
One,
two,
three,
four.
I think that behind his eyes I saw someone who really wants to be seen and
understood.
I kept seeing a little bit of fear behind his eyes and I wanted him to know that
like I was there for him.
I would describe Hana as someone who is very like empathetic,
someone who you know,
decides to take a risk,
but on a very like emotional level.
We did this crazy like hand thing at the end where it was almost just like I'm
here for you.
Like thank you for this time we got to spend together.
I would say that she's in a way courageous because not everyone wants to be
vulnerable.
Why don't we take a step back and just
how do you feel?
I feel like I know things about,
you know I,
I was really surreal.
I don't really know how to put it the words but ineffable,
right?
Yeah.
What you go on a second.
This person would be dope to hang out with her like friends and her as a friend
and we could just like hang out like to that would be cool is I kept getting
each other's contact information if we ever any like advice on something.
Right,
exactly.
Is it done?
I think that we're both very different people,
but we connected on a lot of cool points.
It's called First Fridays.
It just heard of it priced frightening.
People go out and they walk along a Venice Abbot Kinney and they eat food
taco trucks.
So that's just like a thought.
You could bring your friends.
I'll bring my friends.
All right,
that's fine.
I like that a lot.
I don't know.
There's this food trucks.
I'm pretty cool.
Uh,
I'm a mountain's girl,
but I might,
I might build and make an excursion to the beach to see him sometime.
I think it'd be fun to go on a second day for sure.
Hi everyone.
Thank you so much for watching.
Another episode of tea for two,
and this is one of my favorite series,
and I hope you enjoy it.
If you're interested in being in a future episode or click the link in the
comments below.
That's right.
And as always,
make sure you click here to subscribe to more videos from jubilee.
Make amazing content about radical empathy,
all different types of series.
And click here to watch more videos
and we will see you guys next time.